[Música]
bueno les voy a hablar de educación es
libertad o libertades de educación en
esta charla usar de la palabra escuela
para referirme a todas las instituciones
de educación es un comentario
generalizado que la escuela pública en
general es deficiente y que el gobierno
de turno debe entregar más dinero para
su mejor pues su infraestructura es mala
el equipamiento es escaso y los
profesores no ofrecen una enseñanza de
alto nivel
a esta educación se le define como el
sistema público en realidad es el
monopolio del gobierno sin embargo en
todo país existen focos de luz para la
juventud que son las escuelas privadas
no son un sistema pues cada una funciona
con diferentes filosofías y estándares
en general se dice que ellas son mejores
pero son tachadas de elitistas porque no
son accesibles a las personas de menores
recursos lo incomprensible es que el
sistema público tiene prácticamente un
presupuesto sin fin y los políticos
burócratas que creen que crean el
sistema público
ven con malos ojos a las escuelas
privadas pero buscan poner a sus hijos
en ellas la escuela privada se dice
elitista pues es la escogida por la
gente más pudiente por su alta calidad
el padre escoge el tipo de escuela
acorde a sus principios si bien no tiene
voto en la escuela tiene voz en la
educación de su hijo y la escuela se ve
en la en el compromiso siempre de llegar
a un acuerdo con el padre porque si no
nos recibe los ingresos de su hijo el
padre de menores ingresos no puede
escoger a su gusto la escuela y le envía
al sistema público a sabiendas que su
hijo recibirá una informe o educación de
menor calidad
el sistema público busca homogenizar es
decir no necesariamente educa sino que
adoctrina de acuerdo al pensamiento de
los políticos de turno y los burócratas
de turno como es gubernamental su
capacidad de reacción es baja y no está
al frente de nuevas tendencias y
conocimientos además de que las
regulaciones re impiden los profesores
no pueden cambiar el currículo
gubernamental y en gran medida los
administradores y profesores han logrado
su posición gracias a conexiones de
sobornos oa dádivas
entonces la pregunta es por qué los
padres de menores recursos no pueden
acceder acceder a la escuela privada
por falta de recursos por falta de
dinero no es porque los burócratas
políticos no permiten la creación de
escuelas privadas las razones son
ideológicas o miedo a no poder
adoctrinar a la masa perder control
sobre la formación de los ciudadanos
y obviamente creen que la educación es
un derecho que así lo diga la onu no lo
es
lo nefasta o la nefasta consecuencia es
que la mayoría de los niños de toda
américa latina ingresa no a los focos de
luz sino al sistema monopólico
adoctrinador de los gobiernos pero la
solución es simple liberar a la
educación de las manos de los políticos
y dejarla a los padres para que abran
escuelas de cualquier pensión de
cualquier costo pues cualquiera cosa va
a ser mejor que el sistema gubernamental
uno podría preguntarse pero en este
sistema quién quisiera poner una escuela
en un lugar apartado de los centros
urbanos para que esto ocurra las
escuelas tendrían acciones que se
venderían se comprarían y así un colegio
urbano con suficiente capacidad y que ha
llegado al tope de crecimiento puede
interesarse en aplicar su modelo en un
pueblo apartado
este fenómeno ya se da a nivel de
escuelas y universidades en todo el
mundo
la liberación del sistema educativo de
las manos de los políticos así como el
dólar nos liberó para que no manejen
nuestro dinero es una necesidad urgente
especialmente en países como el ecuador
que se encuentran retrasados en todo
aspecto con respecto al mundo
desarrollado pero esta liberación
también se extiende a la enseñanza por
ejemplo es recomendado es recomendable
que se
de cierto tipo de libros de lectura a
los niños no se debe dejar que el link
escoja el libro que él desea leer esa
motivación hace de ellos lectores para
siempre
en lugar de fomentar la duda en los
colegios la escuelas de universidades se
fomenta la certeza lo cual no
necesariamente conduce a mentes críticas
las escuelas son centros donde se
presentan hechos sin posibilidad de
oposición
en otras palabras no se enfatiza el
método de aquella materia que ha hecho
nuestras vidas menos dolorosas la
ciencia y por supuesto entonces tampoco
la experimentación se olvida que
aprendemos a través de la experiencia al
hacerlo nosotros mismos con nuestras
propias manos el estudiante también debe
tener libertad de dejar lo que hace y
cambiarse
especialmente hoy cuando el aprendizaje
debe enfocarse en abrazar el cambio
hay estudiantes que dejan la escuela lo
cual suena fracaso para los padres de
familia pero debemos considerar que como
la educación es obligatoria las escuelas
se vuelven prisiones las similitudes
impresionante proyectores que actúan de
guardianes compañeros que hacen bullying
clases que son centros de aburrimiento y
autoridades que juzgan al niño
continuamente así el cinismo y el
aburrimiento llevan a muchos estudiantes
a tomar medidas extremas y dejar la
escuela
pero los ejemplos de personas que han
transformado
nuestras vidas de emprendedores son de
aquellos que dejaron sus estudios la
razón parece obvia el sistema
obligatorio carcelario retrógrada de
educación no permite el desarrollo de la
natural curiosidad de la mente humana
aquellos jóvenes con pasión por una idea
con creatividad innata se salen del
sistema y crean innovan y emprenden
es decir libertad es la educación
correcta la de escoger la escuela que
quiero para mis hijos la libertad que
lean lo que quieran la libertad de
cambiar la libertad especialmente de ser
contestatario pues ante todo debemos
entender que la educación no es una
ciencia es un arte
lo que caracteriza a la humanidad es que
nadie es igual a otra persona por eso
los sistemas socialistas han fallado en
todo el mundo como probaron sus crímenes
de lesa humanidad en todo el siglo 20 no
existe pues una forma de enseñanza sino
millones de ellas cada persona aprende
lo que le gusta en el tiempo y lugar que
considera apropiados en el sistema
monopolístico del gobierno se busca dar
la misma educación a todos
yendo más allá yendo más allá en el
significado de educación diríamos que es
un intercambio de características muy
especiales entre el maestro y el
estudiante
que fue nuestra primera maestra nuestra
mamá ella nos enseñó sin esperar
recompensa
nos enseñó que solo por el solo hecho de
enseñarnos sin esperar frutos de esa
acción asimismo el maestro enseña sin
esperar frutos de ella sólo espera que
el estudiante saque la mejor nota
posible esa es su recompensa
quién gana de este intercambio
obviamente el estudiante
el maestro se queda
para enseñar a nuevos jóvenes que
continuamente vendrán
aquí me gusta hacer una de una
diferencia intensificado de querer
llamar que se puede hacer en español
cuando digo yo quiero que estoy diciendo
estoy implicando deseo que quiero algo
para mi beneficio es decir es una acción
que espera frutos para uno
amar es diferente es libertad
es decir es dar sin esperar retribución
y esa es la acción del verdadero maestro
no esperan ningún beneficio para él este
intercambio de conocimientos como en el
hogar se da en un lugar bonito es en la
belleza donde florece la bondad
así padre el maestro estudiantes
florecen con un amor a mejorar sus vidas
al final podemos concluir que sí pero
que la libertad es la base de la
educación los niños en libertad se
convertirían en jóvenes que defienden la
libertad y los jóvenes en adultos que
defienden la libertad y ella es el más
preciado principio el cual debe guiar
nuestras vidas pues así se crearían
focos de luz que brillarían como iconos
de libertad en todo el mundo
pues sin libertad cuál es la razón de la
educación la libertad es la razón de ser
de la educación y el amor el metro
gracias
[Aplausos]